well Jenna Bush Hager and Barbara Pierce
Bush have a new book forthcoming
it's called sisters first why that title
why that title well because above all we
are sisters first and it was a play on
obviously being first daughters but we
have been so lucky in our life to have a
twin which meant that we always had a
partner and everything that we were
doing so whether it was kind of the
ordinary experience of growing up in
Texas everything was more fun because
there was someone with us to make it
more magical and then of course as being
first daughter's we had someone else
that was also going through the same
experiences with our parents that
understood
what life was like and so so I guess
above everything we feel like we're
sisters first and then we're daughters
and you know we all play roles in life
but we started off entering the world
together as sisters
Jenna Bush Hager your sister used the
word ordinary yeah what's your life work
yeah it was and I you know it's so funny
people will come up to both of us
all the time and say why you know you're
so normal on TV and it's sort of a
strange thing to hear because you know
we want to think of ourselves it's
exceptional but we are normal I mean we
grew up our grandparents and we write a
little bit about we all what made us who
we are but our grandparents on my mom's
side who don't have airports named after
them who haven't been on c-span
interviewed by people like you who names
are only because we repeat them our work
from Midland Texas my grandpa was a home
builder he built a lot of Midland and
he's you know one of our those two both
of us genna's who I'm named after my
mom's mom Jenna and Harold Welch were
just as much part of our lives as George
and Barbara Bush and in fact you know
they were sort of this corner stone in
Midland Texas is just as much part of
our life as Washington DC so I think we
have this sort of just a position in
life but I don't think people realize
and I also think we've been through
things on the outside that people of
what witnessed but then there's also
personal joys and struggles that we're
going to share in this book that I think
will surprise people
from your upcoming book for years right
up until this day when we walk into a
room or a restaurant are almost any
public space together we invariably hear
oh look it's the Bush twins sometimes
followed by an eye-roll
and then the place will fall
uncomfortably quiet
oh those wild Bush twins when when did
you understand that you had lost the
public narrative about Soviet peace it's
a good question I mean I really think
when we were 18 so when my dad became
president we were or when he was running
for president we were entering college
and until then to Gina's point we were
living in Texas we went to a big public
high school Austin High that is like
every other you know it's almost
made-for-tv that was high school there's
like cheerleaders and jocks and a
marching band and that whole vibe and
then when we were 18 and our dad started
running for president all of a sudden I
think we became more aware that other
people had a narrative of us that may or
may not be true you know there's always
a little bit of truth in a stereotype or
in a narrative but after he was
president and that was a time when there
wasn't actually luckily for us a lot of
social media hallelujah we couldn't own
our narrative because we didn't want you
in many ways we wanted to be college
kids we wanted to experience the world
and wanted to focus on that more than
how did other people perceive us really
and I think also you know what's
interesting is that anybody I think can
relate with the fact that when you're
part of siblings are part of a group or
part of work colleagues somehow you get
kind of characterized as one way or the
other so we've had a really interesting
time writing this book because so many
times people would say oh I mean still
people say it
you're the loud one but really if people
knew us Barbara's far more independent
and really outgoing and real I mean she
commutes to Rwanda as a job she has the
most amazing confidence and it shines
and those that know her see it but then
you kind of wonder and I think everybody
can wonder this like do you fall under
other stereotypes of you or do you kind
of play into that more because that's
what people think of you and I it's been
really fun for us to explore that we've
also seen people we love dearly our
grandfather and grandmother our mother
and father stereotypes in certain ways
and some of those stereotypes of course
are true and some you know it's easier
to simplify people it's easier to call
them one word as opposed to this really
to who they really are and I think we
see this with cable news and no offense
to c-span to we love you but we see this
with with the way that we kind of
simplify public figures and and really
people are complicated and we're
complicated and we've been characterized
as one way and and I think it's fun to
share a story and tell who we really are
one of the story themes during the White
House years for your father you went to
UT you went to Yale and you did it on
purpose so you wouldn't be together was
that true personally also I couldn't get
into Yale
so let's be honest if I could have
gotten LDL maybe I would have a
different narrative there we're very
different and I think thank goodness and
as a mother now I'm such an all of this
we weren't compared I mean Barbra missed
I think one or two problems on her SATs
I missed several more than one or two
and we were always really celebrated for
who we were I love to write I love to
perform and my parents applauded that
they never made me feel like I was
lesser and thank God because I would
need some serious therapy you or not
but I do think us going to different
schools I wanted to leave Texas I was
just curious to go to other places and
meet new people and there was something
I didn't know a single person at Yale so
it was fun for me that challenge of
walking in and thinking what am I made
of and can I meet people but the beauty
of it is we both got then double the
friends because I could become friends
with all of Gina's friends from
University of Texas and she's really
close with my friends for meals so it
also you know there was a real kind of
blessing in it too
twinkle mom I was kidnapped
yo no is that part of the girl I you
wrote about it okay yeah so there were
all these stereotypes that I was that we
were secret service stitchers in the
college years that my friend is not true
but as a first grader at Preston Hollow
elementary I did fake my own kidnapping
who was Twitter first of all I'm twinkle
that was my Secret Service code name
since you were young no when I was in I
don't know what our code that's a good
question I don't know if we had code
names when my grandpa was president we
only had Secret Service for a short
period and we should we should
investigate that but twinkle was my name
when my didn't when my dad became
president Barbara was turquoise it was
based off of our eyes they said I had a
twinkle in my eye I think that has to do
with mischief and Barbara has these
beautiful turquoise eyes and yeah as a
first grader I had a wild imagination
she did it made life fun but complicated
I instead of getting in trouble I acted
like and by the way my story was
perfectly flawless it was exactly what
you read on or see in all the movies
grave and a bald bald man candy the
puppy would have been what was your fire
okay what was Laura Bush's react my mom
is unbelievably calm we've I stood
though I was busted this is the thing
she can shut us down with one look she
never even needs to raise her voice
she's so common and but she was not
happy let's be honest she also I can't
help that pink found it sort of
hilarious
maybe not she found it funny after you
had to tell the Secret Service men you
in fact had not been kidnapped
I faked my own kidnapping so you say
those stories are inaccurate but there
was a long-term story about you a
tollbooth Yale cars did in fact happen
but it was unweighted and you're right
about that well it's not that good of a
story but I don't even by the way this
is how what how the world was back then
I don't even know this story I was with
friends from Yale enough we were going
to a World Wrestling Federation event in
New York what I don't know why we're
gonna be with Chris Jericho Jericho's
here by the way he's got a book so we
can relive relive the story but anyway I
was driving with friends back from New
York through one of the tolls and I was
in a car that had the toll pass so we
went through Secret Service did not feel
hopeful about this we had like one
fighting back do you have to include
this so we lost up but then it ended up
someone in my dorm wrote about it it
kind of became this whole oh it did -
found a life of its own I mean I'm
pretty sure in like the National
Enquirer it took on a life of its own
the national entirety I should read the
New York Times a little bit more than
the National Enquirer
but I remember you've been really
reading the National Enquirer can we
have Bible so that didn't happen but it
was an accident you have to write about
die I'm tired of being the only bad twin
believe me there's plenty of stories in
the book Margarita's Austin yes will
that be in the book yes oh well sure
will but you know what's really funny is
that when we write about our precious
gampy for example my dad's dad and like
these unbelievable stories of Hammond
things he said to me that have moved me
to tears and makes me want to cry right
now that's easy to write because it
meant so much to me writing about
Margaery doesn't Austin not that it was
not that it wasn't easy to write I mean
it's not like I feel guilt about it or
defensive about it it happened it's just
that it wasn't this crazy memory that
meant so much later although I will say
that our parents always said when they
told us they were gonna run or he was
gonna run for president we threw a fit
as teenagers would do we cried you're
gonna ruin our lives and then he said we
want no I want you to have a normal like
this isn't gonna change and that was
sort of naive on all of our parts but
you can have a normal you know college
experience that's what I want for you
you can have it so you know when we got
in trouble everybody I think thinks that
there's based on TV and sort of
stereotypes that there was a spin room
that tried to spin it or or you know my
parents were furious and I'm sure they
were disappointed I know they were
disappointed but more than that they
were also I think sad that they promised
this normalcy that was not delivered
upon and and you know looking back at it
I'm so happy that I had parents that
allowed us to make mistakes I mean
imagine if we were perfect life would be
horribly boring and I don't know if I
don't think we could do it no it'd be
too much pressure to be these political
daughters that never made a mistake that
never were able to stick their tongue
out for example let their hair down and
also as a mom I just can't now with of
two little girls I'm so thankful that my
parents allowed us to sort of explore
our own paths and make mistakes and lead
these three humans and you know also to
learn about empathy and caring and the
big world and how much you know if we
care we could bring light to it because
had we not I don't know if I could be a
good mom I'm not sure if we were told to
be this one particular thing that wasn't
ourselves I could be a mother of my own
girl's not understanding you know that
it's okay to mess up speaking of mothers
you write that Laura Bush was the family
closet hippie and Rastafarians she was
little-known facts she our mom loves
music she loves reggae loves it so
growing up we always had reggae music
playing and we have a number of
experiences with our mom going to hear
great music starting in first grade Paul
Simon was unto her for Graceland so my
mom took us with her but of course when
you're in first grade you're about this
tall so we stood on the concert seats
and I mean I will never forget it and
then a number of other memories I was
just thinking about when I was nine at
camp you could get a care of one care
package and people would ask right their
parents and ask them to send them a CD
it was a big deal to have a CD player at
the time and everyone was getting like
new kids on the block in the bill and my
mom sent me Bob Dylan live at Budokan
which I love well I made her love it she
really wanted us to have good music she
wouldn't say this because she's so
demure and she acts like she wasn't
controlling but I think deep inside that
little Rastafarian wanted us to have
good music taste we which did you hear
she loved been worse and so much that I
actually as a child was convinced she
was going to leave my dad for Van
Morrison not that they ever crossed
paths once she just loved his music that
by brown eyed girl oh yeah and that was
my theme song
Jenna Bush Hager what are you doing
today I am working for The Today Show
and it's really fun it's very ironic
frankly because you know we hid from the
media I literally ran from Dave and I
don't use the word my dad's on a one-man
campaign to use them to end the word
literally you know people will Mila my
four year old said mom Eric told me not
to go he looked literally said that and
I was like what did you just say FA will
be furious because you notice how
literally it's become a word like like
you know they people throw it in as a so
but this is true I literally ran
sprinted in the opposite direction from
David Gregory on the steps of the White
House when I went for a run around the
mall you know we spent all these years
trying to hide from the media and now I
work for them which is so ironic but
also really awesome because it shows
that life is unexpected and it can take
these crazy turns and that if you're so
rigid on what you want your life to be
then you never can experience kind of
the beauty of growing and changing and I
think it also shows you that you can't
judge people you know I had these
stereotypes of a lot of the people that
I work with who have now become Savannah
Guthrie is one of my very best friend
she's here today - she has a children's
book Prince this is where pants that
comes out in the fall and she's one of
my she's my next-door neighbor and one
of my best friends and I think I thought
of her as somebody that different than
she is and I think that you know it goes
to hook with what we're trying to talk
about ourselves that people are actually
more complicated than we usually think
and this is not the first book you've
co-author that's true I've also read
into children's books - children's
with my mom it was a very vivacious
editor she's a little more complicated
to work with you're less than a diva
thank you don't tell my mom don't tell
her I said that why'd you hide from the
media why did I I don't know that I've
hid from the media I maybe and maybe I'm
yeah well I think I mean I'm a very
private person even writing this book
was a leap for me but I'm so proud of
her cuz she was very honest and raw and
authentic in it thank you
there were things I learned about her I
mean even today I've learned this but I
we wrote in silos and I just read her
part cinnamon I was blown away thank you
I think we again were in college and we
were young and so the idea of additional
attention on us was I'm comfortable and
I think I mean it is ironic that Gina's
on TV now but when we were younger we
really our life in college and post
college really was about kind of going
to school
our friends figuring out what we wanted
to do and how to explore you know the
difference that we wanted to make in the
world and starting our career and so
much of that is personal and to me what
was then is very private and so I would
say I probably I guess would still hide
from the media except we're doing this
and she's coming don't she'll be we will
be on tour together yes the book comes
out in October October 24th Barbara Bush
what are you doing these days I run an
organization called Global Health Corps
which focuses on competitively
recruiting amazing young leaders who are
currently solving and will continue to
solve the world's most press
health care issues throughout the rest
of their lives and our lives so it's a
really hopeful way to wake up every day
knowing that there's almost a thousand
amazing young people who are passionate
about serving others and making sure
they can live a healthy and dignified
life Global Health Corps Global Health
Corps she's doing awesome work final
question is there for a sorority or a
fraternity among white house kids I mean
have you ever talked to the Johnson
girls or women I should say or the Nixon
women yeah we have
we definitely have and you know
definitely with Chelsey and Malia and
Sasha you know with Malia and Sasha we
felt unbelievably protective of them and
almost people I think thought it was odd
how protective we were but it isn't you
know we saw ourselves in them we saw our
little selves and then when our grandpa
became president and then when they left
the White House it was the same age we
were when our dad became president you
know being a teenager with your dad as
president isn't always that easy but
it's also incredibly rewarding yeah and
we have had we've had we've kind of been
pin pals with them we've heard sit back
from them we've we'd pins very open
letters to them but we've heard back in
a private way and I'm just so proud to
be part of this group especially when of
the women I mean there are men too but
it seems like the most recent have been
women and I do think we're part of a
group of really awesome women who have
each other's backs and I think that's
the whole point of this book and we're
part of a group that's like that yeah
sure sisters first sisters first can
mean and you know you're part of the
clan we're not going to lead men out but
sisters first can mean more than just
blood sisters all right well given your
experience what do you think is going
through Baron Trump's mind right now as
he gets ready to move in well I hope
what's going through his mind is just I
mean he's an elementary school it's just
yeah that is school and friends and
playing sports are doing whatever
hubie's that he's interested in because
he deserves to be a kid and he has a kid
and we should treat him like that give
him the respect that all of us didn't
always have but we mostly did and I
think I think children of the presidents
should be off-limits period and you can
say what you want about his father who
chose to run but he didn't make that
decision he was in elementary school so
when when people attack children and
presidents who don't you know aren't
political who don't have a say it makes
its mad yeah so sisters and brothers
first here's a cover of the book it's
called sisters first stories from our
wild and wonderful life do you know what
that comes from stories from our wild
and wonderful life to Mary Oliver poem a
summers day at the end it says tell me
what it is you plan to do with your one
wild and precious sight I didn't read
about that in the National Enquirer so I
don't know what now exactly great poetry
thought in the National Fire well
sometimes they do in the crosswords just
kidding thank you so much
the book is out in October thanks for
being thank you
thanks so much that was fun we had a
blast